horror movie sequels have been a fact of
hollywood since horror movies were
invented
one frankenstein is great so how about
another and horror films seem especially
easy to green light sequels for
but even so there have been a number of
horror sequels that have never quite
gotten off the drawing board
here's why 1978's halloween was left
wide open for a sequel which came to be
in halloween 2.
then with michael myers seemingly dead
the plan shifted away from the iconic
serial killer and towards an anthology
style series of halloween related tales
of terror but it didn't last long
this went over very badly with halloween
3 season of the witch which was brutally
rejected by fans
since then the halloween franchise
dropped the anthology idea and has never
strayed from michael myers and his
trademark mask at knife
another massive franchise almost took
the same path as reported in the book
crystal lake memories the creators of
friday the 13th didn't see how there
could be a sequel after jason
ambiguously drowned in the first movie
then he's still there
a plan very similar to halloween's was
devised every year would get a different
horror story but ultimately the studio
didn't want to mess with a winning
formula and they didn't need to make a
flop like season of the witch to figure
that out
instead that anthology idea was funneled
into the syndicated friday the 13th tv
series though which had nothing to do
with the original story and lasted 72
episodes
after directing piranha joe dante was
offered the opportunity to make other
angry ocean animal stories
orca 2 and the hilariously named jaws 3
people zero
orca is a fairly tasteless 1977 jaws
ripoff produced by the infamous dino
dilaurentis who is generally known for
much more successful movies like flash
gordon and doom
it's pretty obvious why a sequel never
made it to the finish line the original
orca wasn't that big of a success
in contrast jaws three people zero was
going to be a spoof
john hughes and todd carroll got as far
as writing the screenplay which offered
a movie within a movie parody of
hollywood with a real shark attacking
people while the film crew makes the
next jaws movie
as dante recalls in the horror history
real terror the script was constantly
being rewritten and he in the studio
couldn't agree on what direction they
wanted the movie to go in
eventually dante jumped off the sinking
jaws ship and went on to direct another
indie horror hit
howling anyone left on the film
ultimately decided the industry
satirizing film wasn't really in the
spirit of jaws and abandoned the project
in favor of making them more
conventional but still pretty weird jaws
3d
peter jackson became an underground
phenomenon with such films as the insane
muppet parody meet the peoples and the
hilariously low budget bad taste
[Music]
as a strong buzz began to build around
him he was offered the chance to write
and direct a nightmare on elm street
sequel to take place right after the
fifth movie in the series
jackson's take was going to be called
the dream lover and like scream it would
have been a self-aware horror film
the concept was ambitious the kids of
springwood would know the legend of
freddie but be utterly unafraid of him
diminishing his power
but freddie was going to manage to kill
someone in a dream again bringing the
fear back
at one point the kid was going to have
to go into the dream world to save his
father
trapped in a coma by the fiendish
freddie the studio made freddy's dead
instead
but all was not lost this script got
jackson's name in the door
new line which eventually resulted in
lord of the rings
one of the things that makes the
original last house on the left a
powerful film is the context of when it
was made
even today viewers can feel the anger
horror and disillusionment that came
with the end of the 60s in every frame
horrors of the time like the manson
killing seeped into the film and remain
as present within it as the day it
debuted
so it's hard to imagine there being a
sequel the gang of scum that assault and
murder two hitchhiking girls are all
killed off at the end of the movie or
wherever there's potentially more money
to be made producers will still keep
trying at one point director wes craven
was considering having two of the
killers come back from hell to kill
again but that idea was nixed
another script was supposedly written
but halted by a tiny oversight the
producers didn't secure the rights to
make a sequel in the first place
that was that there are many horror
characters fans would love to see duel
to the death
a freddy vs jason vs ash movie in this
mold would be utterly irresistible
fans saw freddy and jason duke it out
after all so adding in a blood soaked
ash williams complete with chainsaw
would really make for a wild time
this prospect was seriously considered
at some point but sadly it did not come
to pass
freddy vs jason vs ashe was going to be
the sequel to freddy vs jason but it
never got out of the development phase
why you ask well it turns out bruce
campbell didn't want it to happen
and the main reason was creative
differences as he recalled in a reddit
ama
we couldn't control any other character
other than ash i felt like a creatively
bankrupt
way to go not to mention you're
splitting the proceeds three ways with
partners you might not want
the project didn't totally die at least
it was eventually turned into a comic
book mini-series
a sequel that would have featured
hellraiser's hell priest aka pinhead was
also stopped in its tracks
and speaking of pinhead it's been a long
time since there was a new hellraiser
movie on the big screen but there have
been a total of 10 different films in
the franchise
it's just that most of them went
straight to dvd one of the earlier
attempts to bring the hellraiser gang
back to hollywood was a potential sequel
called hellraiser 5 hellfire
a different sequel involving a matchup
between pinhead and michael myers was
also considered
neither prospect has come to pass
hellfire didn't take off because the
screenplay was too big and too expensive
with the film culminating in a massive
puzzle box sealing around all of london
and attempting to bring the hell god
leviathan to earth
demand for a new hellraiser simply
wasn't big enough to get hollywood on
board
creative clive barker was booted off the
project subsequent sequels were released
only on home video and the actual fifth
hellraiser movie inferno was a strange
psychological murder mystery with barely
any pinhead
welcome to hell bubba hotep was written
and directed by don coscarelli who also
created the legendary phantasm series
and the sword and sorcery classic the
beastmaster
bubba hotep being a horror comedy is
quite a bit different from those films
but very much beloved in its own right
fans have been clamoring for a sequel
for years and they came close to getting
one
the title was going to be bubba
nosferatu cursed of the she vampires
yet it didn't come to pass because bruce
campbell simply didn't want to reprise
his role
as campbell told entertainment weekly i
killed it i killed it for me
i told the creators that i didn't want
to dance around it anymore i feel that
the first one was a nice little gem and
you don't have to make a sequel for
everything
go make it you know get somebody else i
don't want to do it so that one i'm just
going to let go
campbell did drop an interesting
bombshell in that interview ron perlman
apparently almost took over the role
most fans would agree he would indeed
make a fine replacement
amazingly paul giamatti has also been
attached to this possible sequel but
that sort of talent on board she
vampires could more than live up to its
predecessor
with so many classic horror films being
remade and rebooted it's hard for a fan
not to wonder why this hasn't happened
with phantasm
it's simple director don coscarelli is
in control of the rights and he won't
allow it to be remade
speaking to the authors of real terror
he confirmed out of respect to the fans
it's off the table
i get a phone call every week it seems
from somebody who wants to do it
it's something i've been resisting for a
while while the movie could still be
sequalized another major obstacle exists
angus scrim who played the movie's
villainous tall man passed away in 2016.
while some hollywood producer or another
may try to make another phantasm with a
new tall man it's hard to imagine the
franchise without scrim
david fincher a famously exacting
director has been attached to a whole
lot of projects that had never come to
pass and one of them was the sequel to
world war
z while the production of world war z
was a troubled mess it was a hit
making 540 million dollars worldwide
fincher had a strong working
relationship with brad pitt the pair
having previously worked together on
seven fight club and the curious case of
benjamin button
with the first film a success a sequel
was greenlit but this prospective
follow-up finally got cancelled in early
2019 over budget concerns after months
of pre-production
the studio wanted to make the sequel for
less than the original movie's cost
which fincher held firm against as pitt
told collider
we had a really good story which fincher
shepherded really strong story the
things he had planned for it just hadn't
been seen yet
for fans who were sick and tired of
horror remakes cabin in the woods was a
breath of fresh air a bona fide original
horror film it's scary exhilarating
clever and outright hilarious
unsurprisingly it has a strong fan base
who had been clamoring for a sequel for
years
gotta keep the customer satisfied though
the movie wasn't a blockbuster smash
there won't be a cabin sequel despite
some initial brainstorming between the
movie's creators joss whedon and drew
goddard as goddard stated the cinema
blend in 2018
we had some crazy ideas but joss and i
both felt strongly that we didn't want
to do it just to do it
i'm very lucky that i get to keep making
movies i don't need to just go make a
sequel for the sake of making a sequel
the only way we could do it is if we
could do it justice and the truth is
it's a hard one to do justice to
so maybe leprechaun isn't up there with
any truly classic horror movies but the
film has its fans earning it a number of
sequels sending the diminutive demon to
space and the hood
not once but twice again you belong to
the shrimps
even though the 8 film franchise seems
like it could go just about anywhere
there are at least seven leprechaun
sequels that never saw the light of day
at all
some of these never made films allegedly
included candyman vs leprechaun and a
leprechaun set during the gold rush
candyman vs leprechaun actually came
especially close to getting made after
the success of freddy vs jason
but it was the candy man himself tony
todd who turned it down
he loved his character too much to make
him battle a little green munchkin
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tales of terror are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one